if things pan out the way that they look
uh
be slightly more resistant to the
vaccine than
some of the other variants that we've
seen to date so i think there's suddenly
a lot of focus
on that south african variant since the
news
broke and various places were identified
this morning interesting of course
you heard uh in an interview with tim
oliver um from surrey county council
that they were first notified
about the new variant on thursday night
uh but it's only really becoming public
on the scale
that it has done uh today and in a bit
of breaking news in the last few moments
sadiq khan has issued a statement mayor
of london
uh on the new south african variant uh
he says that it's been found in london
uh he identifies uh areas of
uh in west london uh haringey in north
london uh
and in merton uh in uh south west london
uh as places where the new variant has
been seen uh and found
uh and says i strongly encourage anyone
living in these areas to take a test
regardless of
whether or not they have symptoms or not
so that we can monitor and suppress the
spread of the virus
um now it's interesting also hearing
from experts as
you've been doing all day uh uh those on
the
uh immunization and vaccines committee
say really the best way of tackling the
new uh variant is to try and identify
where these epicenters are like the
areas that you mentioned uh and to uh
test
uh rapidly and in quite an intensive way
those areas in order to isolate
the new variants now that of course is a
is a tall order to try and stop the
spread of these
new variants um danny street making
clear that some of the cases that
they've identified today
are from people that haven't traveled to
south africa
uh meaning that there does look at this
early stage to be a degree of community
transmission
uh of the south african variant which i
suspect will concern
downing street and will be something
that matt hancock wants to talk about
uh at the press conference 105 cases of
the
south african variant have been detected
in total and they
uh number 10 said that 11 do not have
any links back to
uh travel so that shows the community um
transmission
they also think that the links back to
travel if you taste if you do contact
racing
uh some of the people who didn't travel
themselves they think there may be two
or three degrees of separation
between the person with it and the
person who traveled suggesting that it
could
uh indeed uh be about to uh we may be
about to see a considerable rise in the
number of
uh cases in the next few days
particularly as the testing uh gets
underway uh on slightly more positive
note i suspect that the government wants
to talk
about vaccines you heard the latest
vaccine figures 9.2
million people who have been vaccinated
in the uk
well on target by the government to
reach their
uh their aim of vaccinating the uh all
15 million in the four most vulnerable
groups by the 15th
of february that effort uh appears to be
well on track
uh the government also confirming today
that everybody in care homes has been
offered a vaccine and had it and the
majority of staff
as well something that the government i
think will be very keen to talk
about that's the first of their targets
they will say has been met the one
to vaccinate people in care homes by the
end of january i suspect that originally
was going to be the focus of today's
news conference
before the news of the new south african
variant
uh moved into interview
and more generally it does appear like
the vaccine strategy
in government is going well despite the
row with the european union
on friday that ended in that
conversation between boris johnson and
ursula vondeline the president of the
european commission
in which the european commission
president did promise that there
wouldn't be
export bars on vaccines produced in the
european union from going
to the uk the uk has some reliance on
vaccines produced
in the european union although a lot of
production is now increasingly going to
take place inside the uk
some seven million or so fisa vaccines
were
potentially at risk if the eu had
enforced that vaccine ban particularly
over the border in northern ireland but
borrowing
but boris johnson in his call with
ursula von dyne secured that guarantee
and there does not now look like there
will be an export ban
yeah sam it's mark austin here now uh
just uh
coming up to five o'clock or we are at
uh just past five o'clock and just
incidentally the figures the viewers can
see their top
left just uh above you there are the
latest statistics
on the vaccine rollout and i guess as
the
the rollout continues sam and goes well
that will lead to more questions about
when
when the lockdown or certainly some
restrictions will get lifted that will
probably come up again
absolutely not least because boris
johnson has uh dived into that debate
today in an off-camera
briefing to journalists where he upended
expectations we had been expected
uh to go back to the regional tier
system downing street made that clear
ministers and made that clear
uh but boris johnson um uh said today
actually
uh that the pattern of behavior of the
new variant suggests
uh that they are operating uh on a
national pattern
and therefore it might make most sense
uh to come back in his words down
through the tier system uh on a national
uh basis as well in other words there
won't be regional differences in how
different areas come out of lockdown but
the whole
of england at least which he has direct
control over will do it up once that
very much
chimes with reports on saturday morning
most notably in the times
the boris johnson might not reopen
schools uh again on a regional basis but
might opt to do them
on a national basis uh that would be his
preferred uh
measure of approach i think whatever the
approach uh boris johnson keen to put
schools at the head of the list
uh of uh things that reopen as soon as
they can he promised of course a review
in the week beginning the 15th
of february and put to publish that on
the 22nd
and here is matt hancock indeed thanks
very much
virus briefing and i'm joined by
professor stephen paris the medical
director of nhs
england and by dr susan hopkins who is
the chief medical advisor to public
health england
and to nhs test and trace i've got quite
a lot of news to bring you up to speed
on and right at the start
i wanted to tell you where we are with
our vaccine program i'm so proud of the
team
who've now vaccinated 9.2
million people across the uk that
includes
931 204
vaccinations just this weekend and to
put that into context
that's one in every 60 adults
in the whole united kingdom vaccinated
in one single weekend it's a mammoth
effort
i know just how much these jabs mean to
people
and i'm so grateful for all the messages
that we get
all the pictures that i'm sent of people
being vaccinated
it fills me with pride that so many
people are doing
so much to help for this
rollout to happen so smoothly and i want
to say thanks to you all
getting vaccinated is an emotional
moment for so many people
and that's because it is about
protecting those who are most vulnerable
to covid we've now vaccinated almost
9 in 10 of all over 80s
in the uk and now as of today we've
vaccinated
over half of all people in their 70s
and i'm delighted that i can tell you
that we have visited
every eligible care home with older
residents
in england and offered vaccinations to
all of their residents
and staff this has been an incredible
example
of health and social care working
together
working side by side to protect people
who are
in the most need as professor martin
green the chief executive of care
england said today
this is a wonderful achievement and one
that is testament to the hard work
of care home staff and our colleagues in
the nhs
and local authorities and i want to
thank every single person who's helped
us get this far
i also want to let you know some good
news on vaccine supply
today we've ordered another 40 million
vaccine doses from
valniva as we've have
all along we've invested early and at
risk
before we know for sure if it'll come
good
because from the start we've taken a
no regrets attitude to backing vaccines
we've tried to leave nothing on the
table if this gets regulatory approval
the valniva vaccine like many others
will be made
right here in the uk the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine is made
in oxford and staffordshire and wrexham
the novovax vaccine is being
manufactured
in t-side and if approved this valniva
vaccine will be manufactured in
livingston
in scotland we didn't start this
pandemic
with a large-scale onshore vaccine
manufacturing capability so we're
building one
all across the united kingdom
and the vaccine program just goes to
show
how important it is the whole uk
working as one together
we now have over 400 million doses of
vaccines on order
this is obviously more than the uk
population needs
and my attitude has always been we
protect
every uk citizen as fast as we can
and at the same time we're generous
around the world
i want to say this to our international
partners
of course i'm delighted about how well
this is going
at home but i believe fundamentally
that the vaccine rollout is a global
effort
one of the many reasons that i'm so
happy with the astrazeneca contract
is that it not just gives us a strong
supply here but because it is the
only vaccine currently being deployed
that is available to the whole world at
cost and because it's logistically
straightforward
it can be practically deployed to the
poorest parts of the world too
so we will protect uk supply
and will play our part to ensure the
whole world
can get the jab another area
where we're helping around the world is
in spotting new variants
and our global leadership in genomic
sequencing has helped us to spot new
variants
here in the uk and quickly to alert the
rest of the world
but there are other countries that don't
have the capacity
that they need last week we offered our
capacity and expertise to other nations
through our new variant assessment
platform
because a mutation in one part of the
world
is a threat to people everywhere for
example
our south african colleagues spotted a
new variant through their high quality
genomic sequencing
and rightly notified the world as we did
with the variant that we discovered here
in the uk
we've now identified 105 cases
of this variant here 11 of those cases
don't appear to
have any links to international travel
there's currently no evidence to suggest
this variant is any more severe
but we need to come down on it hard and
we will
we've already made sure that all these
cases are isolating
and that we've done enhanced contact
tracing
of all of their close contacts we're
surging extra testing
into the areas where this variant has
been found and sequencing every single
positive case working with local
authorities
we're going door to door to test people
in the local area these cases have been
identified in the following postcodes
in w7 n17
cr4 ws2
me15 en10
gu21 and pr9
if you live in one of these postcodes
where we're sending in enhanced testing
then it is imperative that you stay at
home
and that you get a test even if you
don't have
symptoms this is so important so that we
can break the chains of the transmission
of this
new variant and we've got to bring this
virus to heal
so there's lots of good news
but this is a stark reminder that the
fight against this virus isn't over yet
every day we're protecting more people
and getting ourselves
one step closer to normal life but this
is no time to let things slip
so let's all of us do what we must to
get this virus
under control we're now going to go to
questions from the public and then from
members of the media the first question
by video
is from elizabeth from bradford
elizabeth
many of the most vulnerable groups have
now received their first dose of the
fisa biontic vaccine
with a second dose due at the beginning
of april
given the recent attempts by the eu to
block further supplies of the vaccine
into the uk
how can these groups be sure of getting
their second dose
within the already extended time frame
elizabeth this is an incredibly
important question
and you're quite right to ask it and we
have a
high degree of confidence in the
supplies that we have
contracted from pfizer and astrazeneca
and we're working with our european
partners
to ensure those supply chains can remain
open and in the same way that there are
there's some of the supplies made in uh
on the continent so too
a huge amount of it is made onshore here
in the uk
i'm very pleased that we've been able to
have the constructive progress
that we have over the weekend with the
eu
and following those decisions by the eu
i'm confident that we'll be able to
deliver supplies
to everyone who needs it for their
second dose
this is obviously something we keep a
very close eye on
but it is imperative that when the nhs
calls and gives you the chance to get
the jab please do
come forward the next question
is from ruth from rochester also by
video ruth
you have said that clinically extremely
vulnerable adults will receive their
first vaccination
by the middle of february yet there are
many gp surgeries that are still
struggling to get through group one with
the stocks they have
they have no idea when those in group
four would be able to receive their
first vaccination
please could you tell us if you are
going to extend the deadline or if you
will make sure that the gp surgeries
have enough stock to be able to complete
that first
vaccination roll out by the middle of
february
please could you also tell us why social
care staff are in group two
yet unpaid carers are in group six
those unpaid carers often do more work
with their clients
than those in group two and for much
longer hours
please could you explain the difference
between their groups
thank you well thank you ruth for those
two questions
uh on the first yes we do have enough
supply
to be able to hit the target of
offering a jab to everybody in groups
one to four by the 15th of february
and we're working very hard to make sure
that everybody gets that offer
and then i'm very very keen that
everybody
takes up that offer that isn't only
through the gp
services although they are playing a
huge role but also through the mass
vaccination centers
and the hospitals and in kent where you
are
for instance we've just opened a new
mass vaccination center
in foxton i appreciate that's a bit of a
distance from rochester but we've got
we've got the rollout in all different
parts of the country
and everywhere in kent is less than 10
miles
from a from a center to be able to get a
jab
so the rollout is is is is happening on
mass scale as you can see from the
numbers that we're getting through
and we've got the supply to be able to
make that offer to everybody ahead of
the
15th of february and on the
second point on uh on care workers and
where they fit in the priority i'm going
to ask
professor powers to comment on this the
critical thing
is that in category one
we have those who work in care homes and
that obviously is
the most important group to reach
because that's where people who are most
vulnerable
[Music]
reside and then the the
the other categories are determined by a
clinical judgment
and not by my judgment we asked what is
the appropriate order in
in order of how uh how best to protect
the population
as quickly as possible professor paris
yes as the secretary of state has said
those priority groups have been
determined by an independent group of
experts the joint committee
on vaccinations and immunizations and
they have
ordered those priority groups exactly as
the secretary of state has
said to give the greatest benefit to
those who are at highest risk of
the consequences of the virus it's
absolutely
great news that we are making wonderful
progress
in the nhs to vaccinate uh all those
in uh to offer a vaccine vaccination to
all those in those
top four priority groups and i'm
confident that with the supplies coming
through
we're on track to deliver those jabs
into the arms
uh of people in those top priority
groups uh by
the uh target that we set uh two weeks
today so it's no doubt it's a big
challenge but as you will have seen in
recent days
we are vaccinating hundreds of thousands
of people every day
and we are very confident that we're on
track to meet that challenge
fantastic thank you very much ruth next
question is from hugh pim of the bbc
hugh thank you secretary of state
what assurances can you give those in
priority groups who are housebound but
who haven't yet been given a date for
their vaccination
that they will be contacted as soon as
possible
and for professor hopkins and professor
powers how confident are you that the
existing vaccines
in use will be effective against the
south african variant
thank you very much hugh well i'll ask
professor powers to answer the first
question and then
uh dr hopkins ii yes thank you hugh so
so you're absolutely right
uh we acknowledge that there are
individuals in those priority groups who
for various reasons are housebound or
find it difficult to travel
to the vaccination centers so of course
our gps are working hard to ensure that
we can
undertake visits to those individuals
and get them vaccinated
if they're in those priority groups they
are a top priority
and we will we will get to them so i'm
confident
as i've said that we're on track to meet
that target
and that includes ensuring that we're
getting the vaccine
to all those uh who are in those groups
uh
irrespective of whether they can travel
into centres or not thanks dr hopkins
so three of the vaccines that are
that have been used to date in trials
have shown that they've been effective
against the south african variant at a
level greater than was set as the
minimum standard by who and the us fda
we expect all other vaccines to have a
similar level of effectiveness
particularly in reducing hospitalization
and death
and we're doing details laboratory
studies at the moment with the south
african variant growing in the labs
so that we will be able to estimate that
with greater robustness over the next
couple of weeks
thanks very much hugh the next question
is from emily morgan at itv emily
hello thank you secretary of state um i
just wonder how
confident you are that you can actually
contain this new variant
uh because there's clearly community
transmission going on and it's probably
far more widespread than we actually
think
well it's on all of us to contain this
new variant
of course in lockdown when the number of
cases overall
is coming down we hope too that we can
bring down
the number of cases of the new variant
and we're sending in the extra surge
testing and the enhanced contact tracing
to try to stop those chains of
transmission
to stop the spread altogether of these
new variants
but it is not straightforward and
as you say there may be further cases
that we don't know about yet
and are genomic sequencing
is in place to try to to try to spot
them
the most important thing is that people
in the postcode areas that i've outlined
need to take extra special precautions
you know the stay-at-home message is
there for everyone
but in particular in those areas it is
absolutely vital that people minimize
all social contact and
get a test when the opportunity arises
and we're going door-to-door to ensure
that people have the chance
to get those tests uh in the in the
postcode areas that we've described
so this is a it's a big effort trying to
get the
this new variant essentially
finding every single case of it that is
the goal
to make sure that we protect people as
well as possible
and the person medically responsible for
making that happen
is dr hopkins thank you so i i would
just add that the most important thing
that everyone can do right now is is
follow the hands-face space and
stay-at-home message
those are the key things that we'll do
to reduce the virus transmitting to
others
and the additional measures that we've
put in place enhanced contact tracing
enhanced testing in those areas
will help us we will continue to watch
the
genome sequencing data very carefully
for any new variant that emerges
and enhance the efforts that we put to
try
and our best to reduce the spread of
these variants
it's worth saying um in addition i
should have said this
um in my first answer the uh it's worth
saying in addition that
the contact racing system now finds
95 around 95
of uh those uh contacts
uh so it has built up to this very
effective
level and in addition with
by sending people door-to-door and
working with the local authority
and we're trying to find all of the
possible contacts and ensure that they
isolate of course
which is the way that we're going to uh
we're going to get this under control
thank you very much next question is tom
magna from
care as well tom thank you very much
indeed secretary of state
unpaid carers in our audience welcomed
the successful vaccine rollout it
certainly brought
a sense of real relief to our audience
but
unpaid carers still don't feel truly
recognized because they were put in a
footnote
when the jcbi decided that unpaid carers
should be in
vaccine band six so secretary of state
what assurances can you give our viewers
the unpaid carers
will always be at the heart of your
policy decisions
and to professor paris and dr hopkins
when a person in the high priority band
is vaccinated
there's often an unpaid carer going with
them and not being vaccinated at the
same time
this terrifies the unpaid carer who
feels they'll contract covet 19
leaving the person they care for at
greater risk of being left alone
impacting the nhs and social care so
shouldn't unpaid carers and the person
they care for be vaccinated
at the same time whatever the ban thank
you
well thank you very much tom look i know
from my own family just how important
unpaid carers are and we've looked very
closely into where is the right place
for unpaid carers in the prioritization
list and taken the independent advice
that
professor powers talked about so i can
absolutely give you the assurance that
unpaid carers
are at the heart of policy making around
social care
and i i understand the value it's not
just a financial value it's the value
in terms of looking after people who are
sometimes
the most vulnerable and what people give
up in order to do that
i i get that and i think it's incredibly
important on the
specific technical answer to the
question i'm going to ask professor
powers to set out in more detail
well thank you tom and of course in the
nhs we absolutely recognize the huge
value that unpaid carers
bring to our our patients they they look
after them
at home and of course they can prevent
hospital admissions
and of course they can facilitate
hospital discharges when somebody is
well enough to go home
so i can assure you that we absolutely
uh
value uh all that they all that they
bring to the patients that we look after
as i said earlier we are working our way
through uh
the vaccination program according to
those priority groups
set by jc jcvi
i talked about the target we have for
two weeks today of those top four
priority groups but i think it's also
worth saying
that as soon as we have done that we
will immediately be getting uh
going out into uh the next set of groups
uh
and very rapidly as quickly as we can of
course supplies uh
dependent but very rapidly working our
way down those priority groups
so we have a focus on the top five four
priority groups for
the next four weeks two weeks and of
course that's right but
we will also be planning uh
as we speak at the moment uh to keep
that focus on as we move into other
priority groups rapidly
thank you very much indeed next question
is from gordon rayner at the telegraph
gordon
thank you secretary of state um you've
stressed the need to break the chain of
transmission
of the new strain and in other countries
where a new strain is discovered
they've isolated the areas where they
found them to stop it spreading so
why are we not doing that and have you
ruled out tighter restrictions
in the areas where the south africa
variant has been identified
given that the vaccine is less effective
against it
um and just lastly can i just ask
whether the three of you whether any of
you have been vaccinated yet
i haven't been vaccinated yet but i will
get my
jab as soon as it's my turn and i'm
really looking forward to that um the uh
and i'll i'll ask
the other two as well um the the
answer to the question you have about
the transmission the new variant is
of course we're always looking at what
we need to do there is already a
national lockdown
in place that says that you should not
travel unless it's absolutely necessary
and that you should stay local and we
expect people to adhere to that
everywhere but in particular
in the postcodes that i've set out where
people
should stay at home unless they
absolutely have to leave
and anybody anybody even thinking about
stretching the rules
in those areas must not now
of course uh further measures are always
um are always are always there but we
already have this very
strong set of rules indeed very strong
laws in place
against people uh traveling
unnecessarily
unless it unless uh that travel is
essential so what i'd say is that if
you're in one of the postcode areas that
i set out
if you're in an area where the new
variant has been found
then stay at home and let's get this
new variant totally under control
dr hopkins over to you have you been
jabbed yet so i
i happened because sadly i'm not doing
very much frontline clinical work um
more work in the department these days
but my husband who is a frontline
healthcare worker has been
uh no i haven't been vaccinated yet i'm
looking forward to it like
susan i haven't been doing frontline
healthcare
work so i'm not at the front line if i
do start vaccinating because i
may well have volunteered to vaccinate
so that would be one reason to get it
and otherwise i'll need to wait until my
age band or we get to my age band in the
priority groups
my wife may have been vaccinated because
she was in one of the clinical trials
but we don't know whether she got the
vaccine or the control
thanks very much indeed the next
question is to
jane merrick at the eye jane hello thank
you
um firstly to professor hopkins
does the geographical spread suggest the
south african variant is endemic
and if the vaccines do need to be
tweaked to improve effectiveness against
it
will the 9.3 million people who've
already had the vaccine
or had a jab be able to get a booster of
the tweaked vaccine or will they have to
restart the course
given that they are the most vulnerable
in the country and if i can ask you
secretary of state as a parent you will
understand that the benefits of children
being in school
are not only from learning but the
physical and mental health benefits of
seeing
friends playing in the playground which
helps them sleep better and improve
their
motivation to to do school work do you
think from a health perspective there is
an argument to reopen school playgrounds
for play times only earlier than the 8th
of march if it can be done safely with
eg a bubble system in place it's
outdoors and if it's primary schools
thank you well thank you jane on that
last question before i hand over to dr
dr hopkins what i'd say is we've taken
these actions we've had to take
on with respect to schools we've taken
them with a very heavy heart
um and they are as the prime minister
said the first measures that we will
want to
lift but the this virus is still
absolutely widespread
uh across the country there are still
over 34
000 people in hospital and to put that
into context that's 10
000 more than at the uh than at the
original
peak so we we have a still have a
a lot of work to get to do together to
get this under control and of course i
understand the
implications of the of the lockdown
but we've also seen just the
the terrible devastation that that's
caused by
the virus being too widespread and i'm
very glad to say
that it does appear to be uh to be
coming down in terms of the caseload
um the uh and on the first question i'll
pass over to dr hopkins
so so i think the first thing i would
say is that these cases do not appear
linked at the moment
um i think they're in quite separate
parts of the country and they're more
likely to be related to somebody who
potentially had
asymptomatic infection when they came in
from abroad we are looking to find extra
cases in the community to see if there
where we can find links
and to try and close down and eliminate
uh
the transmission between people i think
it's really important to also add
that with the or value just below one as
it is in the vast majority of the
country
that we can reduce these cases
of the new variant and along with
additional testing and people taking
even more control than they are normally
then this will all help us do that in
terms of the tweak vaccine we're already
working and looking
at that looking at what mutations are
particularly common
that might be important to be put into a
tweaked vaccine
it is unlikely that people would have to
start again much more likely that it
would be a booster shot
a bit like the annual flea vaccine
thanks very much jane
a final question is from jonathan walker
from the birmingham mail
and newcastle chronicle
uh hello hello secretary um the north of
england appears to be doing well
in terms of rolling out the vaccine
you'll know there have been suggestions
that areas
have been fastest in getting people
vaccinated or have supplies
cut to help other areas catch up but can
you tell us if that is the case and are
you able to tell us what
portion of england's supply of vaccines
is you to go to the northeast
um in february and march and i'd also if
i may like to ask
dr hopkins or professor paris about the
south african variant
and as far as we know is it more
infectious and under variance is it more
likely to cause
serious illness how concerned should
people living
in the areas identify today be about
their own health and welfare
thanks jonathan i'm very grateful that
you're asking this question because i
want to put to bed
a myth that has been circulating in some
cases
online about the fair share of vaccines
and the northeast is getting its fair
share of vaccine
birmingham in the midlands is getting
its fair share of the vaccine the north
west is getting its fair share of the
vaccine
and we're making sure that the vaccine
goes to all parts of the country
in fact all parts of the whole country
including
all of the devolved areas and making
sure that that happens
on a fair basis according to need
now the north of england has done
absolutely
brilliantly in the vaccine rollout
the northeast was the fastest out of the
blocks
the north west is going great guns too
and i'm really really grateful to
everybody who's working so hard
there is as you know a bumpy supply
schedule for the whole country and if
you look on
coronavirus.datagood.gov.uk
and click on the link to vaccinations
you can see that across the country
there are some days when we do you know
like saturday over half a million uh
vaccines there are other days when we do
200 300 000 vaccines this is according
to supply across the country
as a whole and so if your area
has a few days where supply is lower
than it has been
then that is because of the supply
available nationally
and our goal is to get the supply in and
then
out as quickly as feasibly possible i
think
the nhs are doing a brilliant job of
that and i think they're doing a
brilliant job of it
in newcastle and making sure that people
get protected
we've got to make sure that there are
fair shares everywhere
and we will do that on the second
question i think that was definitely a
question
for you dr hopkins thank you so um on
the south african variant
we know that it's similar in
transmissibility to the variants that
we're seeing now
almost endemic in the uk pretty much
everywhere we're seeing
the variant that first erosion kent so
we want to reduce the transmission of it
by the same measures that we have in
place
we do not have evidence that it is
causing more severe disease than the
variants that are circulating in the uk
but what we know is that it's got
slightly more mutations some more
mutations in the
part of the protein the spike protein
that
is causing it perhaps to have the
diminished effectiveness of vaccine but
still very good
and we want to prevent that spreading
because what we want to do
is to prevent viruses with mutations
being able to acquire more mutations
which they will do over time
so everything we can do to reduce the
spread of this variant
to detect cases with it and break the
chains of transmission are essential
thanks very much jonathan um the um
the only thing i just want to add one
thing to that which is that
for 40 years we've had a flu vaccination
program and every year the flu
jab is updated to make sure that it is
as effective as possible against new
variants so this is a standard part
of what the nhs s does every autumn to
protect
us against the flu
and i hope through this vaccination
program and then through the work that
we're doing
with the vaccines manufacturers and the
scientists
will be able to get the coronavirus jab
to the same place that it's something
that people have
as standard doing that does mean
building that manufacturing capability
onshore
which is part of the task that's
underway right now
it also means getting the science right
exactly as dr hopkins
has set out that is the goal here
there's an
awful lot of work to do but in the
meantime
the the the vaccination program is
rolling out well
and when the call comes please take the
jab and for everyone
let's keep this under control by staying
at home wherever possible
and following hands face space because
the basics
are critical and everybody has got a
role to play
thanks very much indeed see you soon
matt hancock there on the numbers the
latest jabs done and vaccines ordered
40 million more doses he said on order
and
they could be produced in livingston in
scotland but most of it
about the new south african variant
which
susan hopkins of public health england
said was probably linked
to someone who had arrived with
asymptomatic
infection and had arrived from abroad
matt hancock said 105 cases of the
variant had been discovered 11 with no
link at all
they think to international travel but
he did say
there could well be more it could be
more widespread and it was vital that
people
in the areas affected minimize social
contact and matt hancock saying it shows
this fight against the virus
is not over yet let's join our deputy
political editor sam
coates and sam i mean clearly concern
about the
south african variant and the community
transmission that's going on
absolutely about hancock saying that
they had to come down hard
uh against cases of the new south
african variant that they're discovering
uh spelling out which postcodes uh they
have detected south african variant
cases in and pledging that enhanced
contact tracing will go on for everybody
in those postcodes
in order to try and contain if at all
possible while at the same time
admitting
uh that there were quite a lot of uh
quite a lot of cases possibly some that
haven't been detected but not pledging
uh that there would be any more rules in
order to uh
uh in order to keep people at home in
those affected areas
uh instead saying that if you're in one
of those postcodes it's even more
important than ever
uh that you uh follow the rules the
single most interesting thing in the
press conference actually was susan
hopkins
talking about the effect of the vaccine
on the new variant
and she was actually pretty bullish
pretty optimistic she said 60
effectiveness they had found the
vaccines have against the new south
african
variant three vaccines and trials had
proved
above minimum standards particularly in
reducing hospitalizations
and deaths and stress that they were
growing the south african variant in
labs
and they would have more data soon but
it did mean the vaccine did mean
that the impact of the new uh variant
was less severe than it might otherwise
be
and we could be in a situation where
year on year we get as it were
like annual flu jabs except for
coronavirus to deal with new variants
such as this
yeah and an interesting question on the
variant about isolating the areas
affected uh which happens in some
uh countries or certainly more
restrictions yes and i think that the
steer from that hancock is that's not
where the government's head is at the
moment
uh he said of course we keep all the
rules under review
but he just said that there are existing
rules indeed laws
uh to keep people at home and he wanted
people to
uh follow those even more rigorously if
you're in one of the
named postcodes but it's quite striking
that those postcodes stretch
from kent to the north uh to the
midlands to the east
and so there clearly has been probably
more than the 11 cases named of
community transmission to date
yeah and on the issue of um lockdown and
restrictions
a question about opening school
playgrounds before schools actually open
yes it didn't quite feel like the uh
health secretary was about to
go down that path there are quite a lot
of concerns uh particularly um
for kids of a certain age if you
remember the rules allow
people uh five and under to with kids
five and under to take them out
uh and they can uh as it were be an
extra person if you meet one other for
exercise
but that doesn't apply to uh to five to
fourteen year olds and basically the age
of which they could go out by themselves
meaning that they aren't able to meet
friends without
um with parental supervision meaning
there are quite a lot of kids
uh not getting uh almost any social
contact because the rules
uh prohibit it so there is a problem
there it's not clear that the
governments are about to
change the rules in order to accommodate
that but that is an issue that is uh
coming up increasingly frequently
okay and just on the issue of uh
lockdown what are you gleaning
in westminster about whether we go back
to a tier system
or it will stay as a sort of national
restrictions or
or um i mean what are you understanding
about that
itself was quite clear that he is
actually attracted to the idea of
national restrictions once the lockdown
is lifted uh edging away from that tier
system his argument is that the
variant seemed to operate nationally
rather than regionally and therefore
that would be appropriate and also that
he wants schools to open across england
at once so that appears to be where the
government thinking uh
is at the moment but the the thing
that's animating people behind the
scenes in whitehall
is that this vaccine roller is going
incredibly well
and incredibly quickly and there might
be a point in a month or so where
suddenly there are so many people who
have had the jab
that the conversation switches quite
quickly
uh into a discussion about why people
can't do more possibly even
in advance of march the 8th and trying
to get people not to
go out and meet other people enforce
social contact
because so many people have had the
vaccine might actually suddenly become
the challenge for the government
come the beginning of march it feels
like a long way away at the moment
because only
uh nine million people have had the
vaccine to date but if the rates are as
they are and maybe three million people
a week are getting it
then suddenly restraining people who
have been inside for the better part of
a year is going to become very
uh hard indeed and that could be just a
month a month